Das Podcast UFO mit Stefan und Flo hebt jetzt ab alle Stationen gegen Go, kommt alle an Bord, die Reise geht los. Wir fliegen in die Podcast-Galaxie, zu neuen Podcast-Planeten, der Mensch war dort noch nie, kommt alle an Bord, die Reise geht los. Ich hab Tränen, ich hab wirklich Tränen, das ist so süss, das ist so ein süsses Intro. Die Reise geht aus.
Hier kommen wir jetzt nochmal. Ich habe Tränen, ich habe wirklich Tränen, das ist so süss.
Das ist so ein süsses Intro.
Die Reise geht los.
Ja, komm, hör jetzt auch mal.
Da ist das Intro von Sebastian. Die Reise geht los. Wir fliegen in die Podcast-Galaxie, zu neuen Podcast-Vanieten, der Mensch war doch noch nie, kommt nur da an Bord. Die Reise geht los. Ich habe direkt Lust, eine Podcast-UFO-Kinderserie zu machen. Komplett mit Südstationen geben Go. Aber alle geben Go. Die haben nicht so richtig Bock auf Go. Alle sagen, ja, Go. Wir nehmen Sebastian für dieses fantastische Intro, großartig. Das macht neue Stefan. Komm mal her jetzt, komm her, komm her. Sehr realistisch. Das hat Stefan schon oft geübt, gefaktes Umarmen und gefakt der Körperkontakt. Ich habe das Mikrofon an meinem Körper geschmiegt,
weil ich die nicht echt umarmen wollte, aber den Leuten das Gefühl geben würde, als wäre bei uns so alles okay.
Wie aber. Auf der Bühne
tun sie so, als wäre die Beziehung gut,
aber hinter der Bühne reiben die nur
Mikrofone an seinem Körper.
Oh Mann, ist das traurig.
Aber ich habe wirklich... Alle Stationen geben,
go. Ich habe Lust, eine komplette Kinderserie
zu machen, das Podcast-Ufo. Können wir das nicht mal pitchen bei Netflix oder so? Irgendwie so eine Comic-Serie? Stefan und Florenti, die beiden Astronauten, fliegen auf verrückte Planeten. Ja. Also wie Rick and Morty nur für Kinder. Ja, ich weiß nicht, ob ich es hier verraten darf, aber ich wurde angefragt, um für Kinder Witze zu schreiben in einem Museum. Soll ich ... Also eine Hörerin hat mich angefragt, also hat das Management angefragt, und wir hatten noch keinen Kontakt, aber vielen Dank für die Anfrage, ich habe leider keine Zeit dafür. Aber es ging darum, sehr viele Gags über Federmäuse zu schreiben in einem Doktorkundemuseum für Kinder. Und ich muss auch sagen, ich habe zum einen aus Zeitgründen abgesagt, zum anderen aus mangelnden Fähigkeiten. Weil meine Fledermaus-Gags sind irgendwann beschränkt, muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen. So auch wenn man professionell was mit Comedy macht. Nicht bei Fledermäusen, nur zum gewissen Grad kann ich das. Man hinterfragt auch so ein bisschen an der Außenwirkung so. Warum denken Leute, wenn sie an Fledermaus-Gags denken, sofort an Stefan Tietze? Warum ist die erste Anlaufstelle Stefan Tietze? Wegen meinem berühel at Fledermausi, Fledermausgags und auf. Das waren dreimal sieben Minuten, oder was war das? Es war lächerlich viel. Es war wirklich so in einem Bereich von 50 Minuten Fledermausgags für bis siebenjährige, glaube ich, ohne es so nahe treten zu wollen, der Anfrage. Aber es ist schon eine Menge Fermaus-Material. Ich bin faul vor allem. Ich bin so faul, dass ich sagen würde, wenn ich das dann geschrieben hätte, Fledermaus-Material, wäre ich damit auch auf Stand-Up-Tool gegangen. Klar. Als ob ich dann noch mal neu geschrieben hätte. Ich habe ja jetzt 50 Minuten lang Stand-Up-Material über Fledermäuse. Du bist dann endlich an deinem Ziel, endlich eine Persona zu haben. Endlich hast du ein Image, endlich hast du ein Knackter. Du bist halt der, der die Fledermaus-Gags macht. Ich meine, 50 Minuten für Siebenjährige ist schwer, Fledermaus-Gags für jede Altersstufe ist schwer, aber beides zusammen, Fledermaus-Gags für unter Siebenjährige, die wahrscheinlich nichts über Fledermäuse wissen. Ja, aber das kann man sehr zu eigen machen. Also man kann auch Gags über Giraffen machen und die checken es nicht.
So, das war schon meine Taktik im Kopf.
So, liebe Kinder, das war der lustige Tiger.
Ich hoffe, ihr habt alle gelacht.
Und jetzt einen grossen Applaus für Stefan, den Fledermausliebhaber.
Stefan, wuhuuu!
Hier ist Stefan.
Hey, Leute, ähm, hey.
Ich sehe euch ja nicht, ich sehe ja nur euch jetzt über Ultraschall, weil Ultraschall, für die, die es nicht wissen, ist einfach nur sehr lauter Schall. Der ist nämlich in einem Frequenzbereich, den wir nicht hören können. Frequenzbereich, den wir nicht hören können, oder wie Dieter Bohlen sagt, Gesang. Ein Vater muss sich einen Lachen vergreifen. Gut. Ein Vater in der letzten Reihe. Joss auf die Uhr. War es Husten? War es der Krebs? Noch 49, 50. Fledermaus. Sind Flughunde das gleiche wie Fledermäuse? Nein. Nein. Fuck. Ich habe 48 Minuten Flughund-Gags. Ist nicht auch der Code von Fledermäusen sehr wertvoll, dieses Guano? Guano-Apes! Da wäre der Bogen direkt in Guano-Apes die Musik. Sandra Nasic, die war auch bei X-Faktor damals in der Jury, hat uns, glaube ich, ein Jahr gegeben. Ach so, jetzt verstehe ich es. Okay, jetzt X-Faktor. Ich dachte, X-Faktor erst mal das Unfassbare. Ich war ganz anders. Ich wollte mit meiner Moderation, auf dem Moderationshighway weg, ganz weit weg von Ausfahrt Fledermaus. Du hast den, wie sagt man, Hyperspace? Hyperantrieb. Es ist schon wieder so spät, es ist wirklich, vor allem, ich hatte heute meinen Schlafanzug schon an. Stefan Tietze schreibt mir, ich habe heute so viel zu tun, ich habe heute so viel zu tun, ich schreibe dir nochmal, ob wir überhaupt aufnehmen können. Und dann 19.30 Uhr, ich sitze da im Schlafanzug, denke mir, der Tag ist gelaufen, schön irgendwie noch ein Glas Erdmussbutter aufgemacht und dann kommt die Nachricht, ja, lass es aufnehmen. Und das habe ich nicht gemacht, aber es ist ein schönes Gefühl, nochmal die, nochmal den Schlafanzug auszuziehen und nochmal die normale Kleidung anzuziehen. Ich mach nochmal was. Genau, so dieses nicht, geh nochmal raus. Also du kannst ja auch Sachen machen mit Schlafanzug an, aber so dieses, ah, jetzt geht nochmal was. Wo du gerade sagst, abends nochmal das Erdnussbutterglas aufschrauben, geht es nur mir so, aber ich wohne im Erdgeschoss, aber wenn ich nachts noch mal denke, jetzt noch mal irgendwie Nutella oder irgendwas, dann mache ich zuerst die Rollladen runter, damit niemand reingucken kann, weil es mir unangenehm ist, dass ich mir mitten in der Nacht noch mal irgendwie Nutella-Brot schmiere. Weil es ist halt so, ich weiß, ich bin gerade schwach in der Minute
und ich werde, ich will nicht bei dieser Schwäche gesehen werden.
Und dann mache ich wirklich meine Jalousien runter zur Straße hin,
dass entweder die Leute, die vorbeigehen, denken entweder,
okay, der masturbiert jetzt, mit Sicherheit masturbiert er,
und fünf Prozent denken, okay, er macht sich wieder das Nutella-Brot.
Ja, das Erdnuss-Butter-Glas ist offen, die Hose ist unten, was wird er wohl machen? Der Hund hat schon wieder Bock. Der Hund hat diesen furchtigen ängstlichen Blick auf den Augen. Aber auch tatsächlich so diese schwachen Momente. Gibt er im Supermarkt Quengelware, die so direkt an der Kasse ist, und du stehst an der Kasse und du willst Quengelware und du quengelst in dich rein. Du quengelst rum. Aber du denkst dir, wenn ich da jetzt reingreife, wissen alle, die auch noch in der Schlange stehen, er ist schwach. Er ist drauf reingefallen. Er hat verloren. Er ist auf die Quengelware, er ist 38 und auf die Quengelware eingefallen. Deswegen wichtig, immer so kurz gucken, so, ah, da ist noch das Duplo, das ich gesucht habe. Was ich die ganze Zeit gesucht habe. Ach, hier, Entschuldigung, kann ich mal kurz das Twix XXL, wo jedes Stück 50 cm lang ist, kann ich das nochmal haben? Und als hättest du die ganze Zeit danach gesucht, um ja zu verbergen, dass du gerade einfach auf den ältesten Mal getrinkter Trick der Welt reinfällst. Ich bin, vor einer Woche bin ich relativ spät abends zu Hause gegangen, dachte mir, ja, es ist spät, jetzt noch was zu bestellen und bin dann kurz in den Supermarkt gesprungen, um noch was da zu essen zu holen, und dann sprang mir so dieser Block Hefe in die Augen und Mehl, und ich dachte mir, fuck it, fuck it, ich wollte heute Abend eh nur ein belegtes Brötchen essen noch, ich back mir Brötchen jetzt, und da habe ich mir Salz, Mehl und Hefe geholt, das ist eins, wie man braucht, Und da habe ich das gekauft in der Kasse und der Blick dann an den Bäcker vorbei, der war weird, weil ich habe den so angeguckt und dachte, der weiß es. Der weiß es, dass ich mir jetzt selber Brötchen backe. Und da habe ich mich abends, wenn ich noch um neun Uhr oder so in die Küche gestellt und habe mir Brötchen gebacken. Ja, vor allem 20 Minuten kommst du wieder zum Supermarkt und gehst zum Bäcker und sagst drei Brötchen und der Bäcker weiß ganz genau, der Mann
hat Hefe überall im Gesicht.
Vor allem weiß genau, was passiert.
Man geht immer an so Bäckereien vorbei, wo dann steht irgendwie
seit 1653
und ich gehe mit meinen Sachen
vorbei und sage, ja, seit 2018
fange ich jetzt mal an,
ich probiere es mal aus. Hat das schon mal
jemals jemand kontrolliert?
Ja. Also das steht dann seit 1624 und dann klopfte mal, Entschuldigung, kann ich das mal sehen? Welches Bissen haben Sie überhaupt über die Zeit? Ja. Weil es heißt ja eigentlich, seitdem haben die perfektioniert, gute Brötchen zu backen. Kann ich da mal irgendwie ein, also irgendwas sehen? Kann sie ein Schwert? Haben sie irgendwie so einen Helm? Also irgendwas oder weil ich meine, du tatsächlich gerade in Deutschland hast du ja als Verbraucher wahnsinnig viele Rechte. Du kannst ja, du darfst ja Sachen im Supermarkt essen einfach. Du darfst ja eine Weintraube essen, um zu probieren. Du darfst das alles. Sagt er ja und schmiss so ein Regal um. Zickt euch! Du darfst wahnsinnig viel als Verbraucher und ich glaube, du hast auch so Auskunftsrechte, du darfst zu einem Polizisten wahrscheinlich random hingehen und sagen, bitte zeigen Sie mir Ihren Polizistenausweis. Nein, Sie zeigen mir jetzt Ihr Schwert. Ziehen Sie Ihr Schwert aus der Scheide und zeigen Sie mir Ihr Schwert. Ja, ich glaube, du darfst auch irgendwie, oder so bei reduzierten Waren darfst du auch hingehen und sagen, zeigen Sie mir, wie viel das ursprünglich gekostet hat. Und dann musst du auch in seinen Verlies runter und da den Drachen wecken oder was auch immer. In Deutschland muss man sagen, hat man die Lizenz zum Arschloch sein. Total. Ja. Das ist, ich glaube, von Arschlöchern für Arschlöcher. Bitte. Und fahr das bitte langsam. Oder sehr schnell, je nachdem, wo Sie sind. Das stimmt. Ich möchte euch kurz mal einen kleinen Blick hinter die Kulissen ermöglichen. Wissen wovon? Des Podcasts. Ach so. Denn man muss ja sagen, und das wissen ja die Hörer auch, dieses Projekt hängt am seidenen Faden. An vielen, muss man sagen, an vielen seidenen Fäden, die sich verheddert haben und auch nicht mehr gleichzeitig tragen. sondern es ist wie so eine Liliane, Liliane, Liliane, Liliane, ist ein schöner Damenname, Liliane ist ein Damenname, also sie ist schon für einen Damennamen entschieden, ja mein Damenname ist Liliane, Liliane ist Damenname, Liliane ist Dschungelname, ja, gut, so muss man sich jedenfalls das Projekt vorstellen. Es hangelt von Liane zu Liane. Beispiel. Florentin schreibt mir um 20.18 Uhr, am 18.10 Uhr um 20.18 Uhr, oh, das wird sehr knapp. Auch ohne Kontext, bin da vorne nicht geschrieben, auch kein Hallo oder so, oh, das wird sehr knapp, ich hab nur noch 16% Akku und kein Ladekabel in Hamburg. Ja, oh, du erinnerst mich, das war letzte Woche, das war wirklich die aufregendste Zeit meines Lebens. Ja? Es war wirklich so aufregend. Ich hatte, und das ist merkwürdig, ich fahre jede Woche nach Hamburg von Köln. Jede einzelne Woche. Du bist der Jet-Setter. Seit Jahren. Und immer habe ich mein Ladekabel für meinen Laptop dabei. Immer. Nur letzte Woche hatte ich es nicht dabei. Was sind das für Tage, wo man das vergisst plötzlich? Ich weiss es nicht. Ich musste ja das Interface mitnehmen, weil ich wusste, dass wir aufnehmen werden in Hamburg. Und deswegen dachte ich wahrscheinlich so, ich gucke in meinen Rucksack und sehe, ah, Kabel. Und dann dachte ich mir, gut, passt, Kabel. Aber normalerweise sind es die Netzteilkabel. Und jetzt war es die XLR-Kabel und so. Wahrscheinlich ist mein Kopf einfach nur so, ah, Kabel, ja, und dann gehe ich weiter. War das jetzt dein Exkurs zu die verrückteste Woche der Welt, oder? Ja, das war crazy. Ja, und deswegen stehen wir vor dem Mikro und ihr hört zu. Und dann kam, aber dann kam ich in Hamburg an und dachte mir, oh fuck, ich habe kein Laddekabel mehr, und dann hatte ich nur noch 30 Prozent und dann wollte ich noch einen Podcast aufnehmen, hatte mich verabredet für einen Podcast, musste den, also unglaublich peinlich, die ist ja Endtime. Und dann hast du da drei andere Leute, die extra ihre Termine abgesagt haben, sitzen dann im Skype und dann so, ja, ich habe noch 30 Prozent Akku. Gott dammit! Wollen wir dann jetzt aufnehmen, bis du raus bist oder ohne dich? Oder Hallo? Hallo! So ... Da sieht das verfranz so ich habe noch einen film runtergeladen so jetzt kann ich aber nur noch zwölf prozent und dann mussten wir das schon lassen muss sich da leute enttäuschen die extra für mich Termine freigeschoben haben und dann kamst du noch an und dann hast du oh lad endlich die Folge die Leute in die Herzen schon davor kommt nichts davor kommt gar nichts. Und dann hatte ich wirklich nur noch 16% Akku und musste die neue Folge hochladen und es war spannend, es war sehr, sehr spannend. Weil ich musste genau, wenn ich es nicht schaffen würde, es hätte nämlich einige Tage noch gedauert, bis ich mir ein neues Leiderkabel kaufen könnte, deswegen es war sehr spannend. Es war spannend, das war auch seine nächste Nachricht, die Spannung ist unerträglich. Daraufhin meine Antwort und ich muss sagen, sehr supportive. Come on, du schaffst das. Tweets kann ich raushauen, fokussier dich aufs Hochladen. Okay, Arbeitsteilung? Nee, das habe ich gelernt. Beim Erstehilfe-Kurs erst mal Anweisungen geben. Erst mal, wenn Notfall ist, erst mal direkt sagen, Unfallstelle klären, sichern und dann erst mal Aufgaben verteilen. Konzentrier dich aufs Atem. Du rufst den Notarzt. Hör auf zu bluten. Du hörst auf zu fucking bluten und ich leg mich erstmal da in die Sonne. Du, wo ist dein Arm? Reiss dich zusammen jetzt. Also, du schaffst das, fokussier dich aufs Hochladen, Tweets kann ich raushauen. Und ich muss sagen, das hat mir gut getan. Cool. Einerseits wusste ich, dass du mir stets, andererseits wusste ich, wenn ich es nicht schaffe, dann ist die Strafe hart. Das we weiß man, wenn man schon eine Zeit mit Stefan T. zusammenarbeitet. Dann deine Antwort. Ich muss noch die, man muss auch sagen, du schreibst die ganze Zeit auf dem Device, naja gut, ich muss noch die Lautstärke anpassen, komprimieren und hochladen, das ist ein Tanz auf Messerschneide. Ihr seht, wie viel Arbeit in dieses Projekt fließt. Ja. Ich habe gesagt, nein, die haben das gemausert. Habe ich mich verschrieben. Ich meinte, die haben das gemastert. Ich wusste nicht genau, was du meinst. Du hast dann auch gesagt, ich mauser da auch nicht rein, hast du dann die Antwort. Aber man muss sagen, das war die Live-Folge aus Hannover und die haben uns professionelle Tonleute, haben uns die nämlich zurecht bereitet, weil das ist nicht so einfach. Weil sonst klingt das nicht gut, wenn wir das so tun würden.
Man muss ja mischen den Publikumston und unseren Ton,
und das hätten wir nicht hingekriegt mit unseren Wurstfingern
dann auf der Weltscheibe rumgedrückt.
Deswegen haben wir das professionell machen lassen.
Ja genau, aber trotzdem hast du gesagt, ich muss die Lautstärke anpassen,
komprimieren und hochladen, wo ich direkt Panik bekommen habe und gesagt habe,
nein, die haben das gemausert.
Daraufhin die Antwort, ich mausere da auch nicht rein,
aber unser Standard ist, minus 16 Loufs, L-U-F-S. Und das wird sich auch nicht ändern. Meine Antwort, ich bin da progressive, habe ich geschrieben. Warum hängen wir an diesen Zahlen fest? Ja, minus 16 Lufs ist eine, ich weiß nicht genau, was es ist. Aber ich weiß nur, weil mich hat es irgendwann mal gestört, dass im Internet alle Podcasts unterschiedliche Lautstärken haben. Und man kennt es, man hat Gäste, dass die Geisterbahn geladen und irgendwie Serial und irgendwas anderes und keine Ahnung. Und dann hört man die sich nacheinander an und dann hat man immer so Stufen in der Lautstärke. Der eine Podcast ist fünf Dezibel lauter als der andere. Und dann ist der eine vorbei und dann beginnt der andere zu schreien. Das will niemand. Ja, genau. Und dann hast du das Intro von Gäste, dass die Geiste, aber dann brennt jedes Ohr, das Trommelfell weg. Und deswegen, es gibt tatsächlich einen Internet-Podcast-Standard, da hat irgendjemand mal gesagt, Leute, wirklich so ein Bismarck-Charakter, der gesagt hat, Leute, hier sind überall kleine Stämme, ihr habt alle andere Sprachen, ich sag, ich mach mal was, ich hau mal was raus, minus 16 Lufts. Und alle so, wir wissen alle nicht, was Lufts sind, aber wir versuchen's. Seitdem versuche ich, mit allen Podcasts, die ich habe, die ich mache, immer mit minus 16 Loops Lautstärke hochzuladen, damit alles gleich ist. Wie gesagt, ich habe gesagt, ich bin ein Progressiver, du hast gesagt, ich mache es nur lauter, jede Folge muss gleich laut sein. Und da habe ich geschrieben, weil ich Angst hatte, aber nicht, dass wir dann so brüllen. Ja, nicht verstehen, wie Lautstärke funktioniert. Dann hat er gesagt, du klingst jetzt tatsächlich etwas aggressiv. Sechs Prozent. Ich dachte mir, das kann nicht sein. Wir haben die ganze Zeit geschrieben auch. Sechs Prozent. Das Chatten hilft nicht, hast du dann geschrieben. Dann war ich erzürnt. Ich hab geschrieben, du chattest mit dem Laptop, hey. So. Man muss echt sagen, dann haben wir noch diskutiert, mach ein bis zwei Loops weniger, wenn ich jetzt anfange zu schreien, aber es hat nicht geholfen. Im Endeffekt hast du es aber noch geschafft, so gerade mit zwei Prozent, und vielen Dank an Kai und Tom, die das für uns gemischt haben, kleines Feedback, Loops vielleicht noch mal einmal auf minus 16. Ja gut, das sind ja unterschiedliche Welten. Das sind ja so Toningenieure, die mischen ja für Kylie und so.
Fürs Fernsehen.
Was ist da die Lautstärke?
Ich habe keine Ahnung, das ist ja genau das Ding, weißt du, die haben ihren Standard, ich habe meinen Standard und da muss man natürlich nochmal drüber gehen.
So, deswegen, alles gut, alles gut.
Nur mal so ein kleiner Einblick, dass ihr seht, nach außen sieht das immer so einfach aus, aber es ist da ganz schön seidene Fäden. Und dann vor allem, dann sitzt du da so, was war das für eine Zeit? Ach, 20.16 Uhr. 20.16 Uhr. Primetime. Du sitzt in Hamburg, 20.16 Uhr, dein Laptop ist aus. Stimmt. Was macht man in Hamburg um 20.16 Uhr, wenn dein Laptop auf ist? Und dann denkst du dir so, ah, okay, gut, da kann ich ja noch ein bisschen Filme gucken. Ah, nee, scheiße, ja. Ich kann ja ... Dann mache ich noch ein bisschen ... Ah, ich habe ja noch mir ein paar Videos untergeladen auf meiner Lab. Ach, nee. Ah, dann kann ich ja noch ein bisschen meinen Monitor putzen. Ah, nee. Ah, shit, jetzt, ich wollte noch ... Und dann sitzt du da und merkst plötzlich, mein gesamtes Leben hängt am Internet. Man kann Laptop-Bildschirm nur putzen, wenn der Laptop an ist. Ja, und dann wandert man so durch die Wohnung und denkt sich so, aha, was ist das jetzt hier, ein Besen? Mitbewohner. Aha, okay, soll ich was kochen oder was? Und dann denkst du dir auch, hast du so ein Buch in der Hand und denkst dir, das ist jetzt mein Leben? So tief bin ich gesund. Oder man denkt, jetzt Brötchen backen. Ich habe mir tatsächlich eine feine Pilzpanne gemacht. Eine feine Pilzpanne gemacht. Eine schöne Pilzpanne gemacht. Und tatsächlich habe ich geniale Sachen gefunden. Wenn du mal irgendwie mit offenen Augen durch die Welt gehst, findest du wahnsinnige Dinge. Und zwar, es gibt getrocknete Pilze. Also da gibt es jemanden, der fängt Pilze und trocknet die aus auf der Heizung. So Herbarium, wie so ein Herbarium. Ja, und lässt sie dann im Supermarkt liegen. Und dann kommst du vorbei und sammelst die auf. Das sind aber dann keine echten Pilze, sondern Pilze minus Wasser. Und alles, was du tun musst, ist die ins Wasser zu werfen und die saugen sich voll und sind dann wieder Pfifferlinge. Pfifferlinge. Also es ist wirklich verrückt. Pfifferlinge sind, Pfifferlinge gehören in eine richtige Pilzpfanne, finde ich auch rein, weil die haben so einen ganz tollen Eigengeschmack. Und die knistern komischerweise immer, wenn man sie isst. Ist das jemand schon mal aufgefallen? Gibt es da Wissenschaftler da draußen, die das mal untersucht haben? Ich habe keine Ahnung. Und dann auch so dieses Pfeudoputzen. Also das ist dann so. Pfeudoputzen mit Pfefferlinge-Pilzpfanne. Du weißt einfach, das ist ein Pfefferlinger Pfeudoputz. Und du denkst dir, was putze ich da jetzt ab? Jetzt ein geputzter Pfefferlinge-Pilzpfanne-Pfeffer. Eine schöne gepfefferliche Pfefferlings-Pseudopilzpfanne.
Oh, Alterationskochen finde ich nicht schlecht. Oh, finde ich gut. Gab es das nicht immer im Süddeutsche Zeitung Magazin, so drei Sachen, die im gleichen Buchstaben anfangen? Oh, finde ich super. Gab es das nicht genauso schon vom SZ-Magazin? Also wir machen eine Flunder mit Flunderfilet mit Fenchel, Flunderfilet mit Fenchel, Pfeffer, ne ne ne ne ne ne ne, ah danke, keine Schlechtnieden, keine Schlechtnieden, wenn du mich brauchst, ich bin hier. Ich ste dann damit kochen wollen, aber ich habe keine Ahnung. Ich glaube, es sind Bakterien, das ist eine Bakterienart und dann kann man jeweils Würfel kaufen. Ist es ein Würfel zusammengepresste Bakterien oder ist es ein Trägermittel? Was ist das Trägermittel? Ich weiß gar nichts, da steht einfach nur Zutaten, Hefe, das ist ein Klumpen Bakterien, warum sehe ich diesen Klumpen? Aber auch so Zutaten, 80% Hefe. Ja, wow. Ja, und was? Und was noch? Packung? Ich rechne oft so Sachen auf Produkten zusammen und da kommt nicht im Ansatz 100% dabei raus. Was ist der Rest? Luf, 12 % Salz, 8% Zucker, 4% Curry, das sind nicht mal 20! Und jetzt die restlichen 80? 30% Fragezeichen, Leute! Leute! Ja, nee, man weiß es nicht. Und dann, genau, und dann geht es halt auf. Und dann musst du, und dann habe ich am 9 Uhr abends angefangen, Brötchen zu backen. Und dann ist mir aufgefallen, oh, doofe Idee. Weil das dauert halt einfach ewig. Weil du musst alleine eine Stunde das ruhen lassen. Ja, das ist immer so bescheuert, dieses Ruhen lassen. Bescheuert. Aber ich habe es ein bisschen zu wenig gemacht. Und am Ende kamen sehr kleine Brötchen noch raus. Also ich habe im Endeffekt, und ich hatte sehr viel Hunger. Heißt, ich habe dann aber locker so sechs Brötchen gegessen. Kleine Brötchen kamen nur raus, ganz kleine, aber der ganze Klumpen Hefe war weg. Das heißt, mit so einem Klumpen Hefe kannst du einfach, du kannst drei Bleche Zimtschnecken und so machen, weil Hefe geht ja wahnsinnig auf. Nicht bei mir, weil ich halt die Wartezeit nicht hatte. Das heißt, ich hab am Ende so einen Klumpen Hefe gegessen und seitdem bin ich auch so ein bisschen aufgebläht, hab ich das Gefühl. Es ist ja viel effektiver, die kleinen Brötchen zu essen und dann gehen sie im Bauch erst auf. Im Bauch gehen sie auf? Das spart man Kalorien, weil du hast ja... Ja, und Platz. Ist ja dann erst im Nachhinein. Und meine Wohnung ist nicht voller Brötchen. Ja, ich erinnere mich aber noch mal, wie ich beim Simpsons Magazin, ich habe als Kind Simpsons Magazin gelesen, und da war dann so ein Gewinnspiel, ja, schick dein Rezept ein für den Sommerdrink und gewinne Super Soker. Ich dachte mir, geil. Der Simpsons Super Soger? Nee, normales Super Soger. Achtung, Achtung. Oh, Vorsicht, Vorsicht, Vorsicht, da kommt ein Bild runter. Und dann habe ich meinen Sommerdrink gemixt, ja, Wasser, Zucker, Zitrone. Und dann dachte ich mir, okay, das ist ein bisschen wenig, das sieht wenig aus. Und dann dachte ich mir einfach, weil ich dachte, ich bin clever, dann dachte ich, um das Rezept ein bisschen länger zu machen, mache ich noch so vollkommen willkürliche Wartezeiten rein. Also wirklich Zitrone ausdrücken, Zitronensaft 20 Minuten lang in den Kühlschrank stellen, dann Krug mit Wasser füllen und zehn Minuten Ruhe.
Einfach nur, damit ein bisschen mehr auf dem Blatt Papier steht.
Ich nehme oft einfach so eine große Schüssel, aber ihr könnt auch einfach alle anderen Dinge nehmen, wo Wasser reinkommt.
Bei mir hat es auch immer oft geholfen, wenn ich jetzt ein bisschen draußen stehen habe.
Das ist immer das Beste an Tutorials. Ich nehme Leitungswasser, ihr könnt aber auch Wasser aus der Flasche nehmen,
oder ihr destilliert Regenwasser, oder ihr geht zum Meer und nehmt euch da was raus und jagt es durch einen Salzfilter und ja Wasser ist schon klar. Und dann so Dinge werden dann übersprungen, die aber wichtig sind. Sowas wie und dann kommt einfach ein bisschen Natrium dazu und dann kommt noch ein bisschen und dann denkt man was? Stopp, stopp, stopp, warum erklärst du das nicht? Was kann man noch nehmen? Tatsächlich nicht gewonnen. Keine Super-Super gewonnen. Wer hat gewonnen? Ich weiß nicht, wer hat gewonnen. Wer hat die Super-Super gewonnen? Weißt Ich weiß nicht, wer gewonnen hat. Aber einfach, weil ich vor allem als Elfjähriger denkste, du bist cleverer als die Simpsons-Helf-Redaktion und kannst die verarschen, indem du einfach so willkürliche Dinge... Kann das sein, dass man als Elfjähriger cleverer ist als die Simpsons-Helf-Redaktion? Du bist ein Jahr älter als Bart Simpson, also hallo? Bart Simpson ist ja das klügste Kind der Welt. Ist zehn.ster Kind. Zehn? Ja, Lisa ist acht, Bart ist zehn. Bart ist clever, Lisa ist ... Lisa ist klüger, aber Bart ist cleverer, würde ich sagen. Na gut, ich hänge da jetzt nicht an der Definition. Du, ich habe das Simpsons Magazin gelegen, du nicht. Aber auch, ich habe mich tatsächlich letztens intensiv mit Schimmelkäse beschäftigt, auch abgefahren. Bisschen wie Hefe. Vor allem, also man denkt sich ja so, wir wissen ja, was gut ist und was nicht, weil wir blicken zurück auf Geschichte. Aber es muss ja irgendwann mal eine Person gegeben hat, die sagt, oh der Käse schimmelt. Lecker. Ich hau da jetzt mal rein. Ich stecke den mir jetzt mal in meinen Mundgöbel. Das wollt ihr alles wegschmeißen? Die ganze Ladung wollt ihr wegschmeißen? Vor allem, wie man diesen Blauschimmelkäse macht, ist, du machst Schimmel auf Brot, du lässt Brot liegen, bis es schimmelt, dann packst du dieses schimmelige Brot in Mixer, pürierst es klein und dann spritzt du das in den Käseleib rein, so dass der Schimmel schon da drin ist und sich an dem Brot ernähren kann. Und dann ballerst du das Ganze irgendwie dann in ein Lager und dann kann sich der Schimmel, weil der hat ja so Adern, also Gorgonzola und so, der hat ja so Schimmeladern und das kommt daraus, weil die das da reinspritzen und dann stechen die immer wieder Löcher rein, damit Sauerstoff kommt, damit der Pilz, damit der Schimmel wachsen kann. Und der Schimmel so, what, was soll ich? Erst werde ich geschreddert, dann werde ich in Käse gespritzt, dann werde ich gestochen. Leute, ich liebe es. Aber wirklich, wer ist auf die Idee gekommen? Es klingt wie ein Prank. Es klingt wie ein, weil man es reinspritzt erst und dann erst mal wegstellt. Ja, genau. Und es klingt so wie, ist das mal? Bruder Gregorius. Oh Gott, da kommt Bruder Gregorius. Und dann? Und Bruder Gregorius. Wow. Da kommt Bruder Gorgonzola. Und man will den Pranken mit dem scheiß Gauder. Und dann geht er um die Ecke und nach einem Monat ist Gorgonzola einfach so ein Riesenthink. Aber Schwester Babybel, er ist überhaupt nicht auf uns ein Prank reingefallen. Es ist ja auch so krass, es gibt ja so Dörfer, auch in Süddeutschland, wo einfach der gesamte Käse einer Käsemarke kommt aus diesem einen Dorf. Und da gibt es in dem Dorf 50 Einwohner plus riesige Käsefabrik. Und da gibt es sonst nichts und es kommt alles alles daher. Und die lassen sich Milch liefern und machen Käse und verfrachten den 30% Export übrigens bei Käse in andere Länder und Wahnsinn. Da muss man sich echt mal, auf Wikipedia kann man unendlich viel Zeit verbringen. Ja, muss man wirklich sagen. Unendlich viel Zeit. Aber ich bin auch nach maximal drei Zeilen genervt. Also gelangweilt. Und dann der nächste Artikel. Und dann merke ich mir mal so bruchstückhaft ein paar Zeilen aus einem Artikel.
Ja, man müsste das so, weil auf Wikipedia sind ja Essays verboten, die wollen ja spezifisch keine Essays, aber Essays, die Idee eines Essays ist ja, machen langweiliges Thema interessant und eigentlich müsste man für jede Wikipedia-Seite nochmal dasselbe Thema als Essay, Also vor allem das Blöde an Wikipedia-Artikeln, das ist halt so, dieses schlechte Referate beginnen immer mit Biografie. Napoleon Bonaparte wurde 1540 und es ist mir scheißegal, wo Napoleon Bonaparte geboren wurde. Sagt mir, wie der abgeknallt hat! Wo ist der Stein gegangen? Komm schon! Und dann so, so. Und seine Eltern waren, ist mir noch Pate abgeknallt, oder nicht? Hat die Alte gebumst, oder was? Oh Mann, ey, nervig. Aber so sind Wikipedia-Tigler auch aufgebaut, einfach weil es akkurat ist. Da müsste man noch mal jeden irgendwie cool machen, dann müsste man so, Napoleon Bonaparte, Peng, Bum, Peng, Cholera, Pest, Bonjour Monsieur. Das war Napoleons Bonaparte Leben, kurz vor der Schlacht von Waterloo, seiner letzten Schlacht und so weiter. Und wie es weitergeht, erfahrt ihr im Artikel. Einmal in normaler Form, einmal in so einem schönen Dreieakter. Wenn man so einen Spannungsbogen hat, dann ist man traurig, wenn sie sterben. Nicht schon in der ersten Zeile Spoiler, wann er stirbt, dass er stirbt. Top 5 der nervigen Artikelanfänger. Ich fange an. Ja, damit du nicht Nummer 1 machen musst. Auf Platz Nummer 5, es wird etwas zitiert, von dem man denkt, es sei aktuell, und dann heißt es, keine Ahnung, plötzlich haben die Grünen wahnsinnig viel Erfolg. Ob sie es jetzt auch weiter schaffen? So titelte die Süddeutsche Zeitung vor 30 Jahren. Oh nein! Du denkst dir, geil! Das ist Platz Nummer fünf. Artikelanfänge, das ist ein sehr spezielles Thema. Ich hab grad nicht aufgepasst.
Nee, war jetzt die richtigen Rubrik? Hallo? Ja, du kannst auch Tankstellen-Snacks machen, wenn du willst. Ich bin grad von Topical Eye drüber gelaufen, aber hier ist jemand. Du, wir können auch eine Hybridliste machen, du kannst auch Tankstellen-Snacks machen. Nee, Tankstellen. Auf uns fünf ist bei mir Jet. Auf Platz Nummer drei der nervigen Artikelanfänge sind Aufzählungen. Niemand mag Aufzählungen. Eine Flasche Wasser, ein Stück Brot, vier Beefy. Das war alles, was Kevin mitnahm, als er von zu Hause aufgebaut wurde. Das war Werbung, dieses Artikel. Als ob ein Satz dadurch interessanter wird, dass er kurz ist. Nervig. Okay, Platz Nummer zwei der Tankstellen. Ich mag BFT. BFT ist günstig, ist auch manchmal an Orten, wo man keine Tankstelle erwartet. Man denkt, du, jetzt eine Tankstelle und dann kommt die BFD im Neck und man denkt, yes, mein Platz Nummer zwei. Platz Nummer eins der nervigen Artikelanfänge sich auf einen Detail fokussieren. Sein Stift tippte nervös auf dem Schreibtag. Oh, nee, mir wurde gesagt, man soll das machen. Nein, das ist nervig. Weißt du, da geht es dann um eine Gerichtsverhandlung und es beginnt mit, Schweiss lief ihm in die perfekt gerichtete Krawatte. Darius F. wusste noch nicht, dass er heute zum Tode verurteilt wird. Furchtbar. Mega Artikel. Warum wusste er das nicht? Warum ist das schiefgelaufen? Bis jetzt dachte er, er würde nur wegen eines Verkehrsvergehens vor Gericht kommen. Doch dann sagte seine Frau Brigitte aus. Das klingt nach einem grossen Rechtsproblem. Brigitte, schwarze Haare, rotes Kleid, schwarzer Ring. Auch sie tippte nervös mit dem Stift auf ihren Blog. Hört auf mit dem Stift. Der halbe Gerichtssaal tippte nervös mit dem Stift auf den Schreibblog. Aber alle rhythmisch. Mir wurde aber, ich habe ja Journalismus studiert, und mir wurde gesagt, Es gehen keine zehn Bachelor of Arts in Journalism, International Journalism, und da wurde mir beigebracht, dass man so anfängt, wenn man Reportagen schreibt. Also, und ich glaube, da ist das Problem. Das Problem für diesen Grund, und ich verstehe, dass es total nervig ist, weil es oft so wirkt, als ob es gemacht werden musste, aber der Typ auch keinen Bock hat, das so zu schreiben. Es wirkt so, das ist einfach fast ein Journalistenschulenproblem, glaube ich. Bei mir wurde das auch mal gesagt. Beschreib erstmal die Situation, das ist eine Reportage. Was ist das Problem? Es gibt einfach keinen guten Anfang. Deswegen fang einfach an.
Bochum, Deutschland.
Gestern wurde der Typ verurteilt,
und das Besondere am Prozess war, dass irgendwie... Es gibt einfach keinen guten Anfang. Deswegen, fang einfach an. Bochum, Deutschland. Sag mir einfach, gestern wurde der Typ verurteilt
und das Besondere am Prozess war, dass irgendwie man am Anfang,
einfach, fang einfach an.
Erzähl es mir, wie du es mir erzählen,
es gibt ja dieses Erzähl es mir, wie du es einem guten Freund erzählen würdest.
Und du würdest ja nicht gehen, du Stefan,
gestern zerbrochene Scheibe, Tränen und ein verschmierter Boden.
Ich würde in den Insider reden und sagen, ey Alter, weißt du was, so würde man aber auch nicht lesen. Ey Alter, gestern hat die, Brigitte, kennst du doch, von früher, aus der neuen A. Ah, ja. Das willst du alles, so willst du ja auch keiner Herr. Ah, ja, ja. Erzähl mir mehr. Ich habe einen Arbeitskollegen, dieses Bild hinter mir, ich habe einen Arbeits, ja, das war es jetzt, jetzt quält er drunter auf mich. Ich habe einen Arbeitskollegen, der, man kennt das ja manchmal, verfängt sich Schleim im Hals, der hustet nicht ab. Das macht einen wahnsinnig. Aber ich habe nicht die Vertrauensbasis, ihm zu sagen, dass er jetzt bitte einfach abhusten sollte. Weil wenn ich die ganze Zeit so reden würde, dass er halt die ganze Zeit wissen muss, und natürlich, ich verstehe auch nicht, warum er nicht von sich aus das Bedürfnis entwickelt, das abzuhusten. Bei dir würde ich sofort sagen, bei dir würde ich sagen, lohnt ihn, das klingt gerade einfach unangenehm, bitte huste ab.
Da bräuchte es mehr Zeichen, es bräuchte mehr Zeichen, wir müssen so ein Zeichensystem entwickeln, dass man wirklich so sich auf dem Hals tippt.
Was habe ich im Hals? Was habe ich im Hals? Warum soll ich meine, was soll ich? Was ist am Hals?
Stopp. Hals ist rot.
Apu.
Weiter.
Quickie-Markt.
Simpsons Quickie-Markt.
Simpsons.
Wie heißt der Verkäufer beim Quickie-Markt?
Genau.
Apu.
Wie hieß, wir haben ein Problem.
Abbruch?
Nee, Space, Weltraum, wir haben ein Problem.
Houston.
Ja, und jetzt zusammen? Up Houston. Apu, Houston? Apo Houston. Richtig, jetzt denk nach. Abhusten. Richtig. Aber vielleicht wissen manche Leute einfach nicht, dass es irgendwie unangenehm ist. Ich habe das Gefühl, es gibt manche Dinge, die sind noch nicht in der Welt etabliert, dass sie scheiße sind. Jemandem ein Bein stellen. Da weiß jeder, macht man nicht. Mega, äh. Nee, macht man nicht, Stefan. Aber zum Beispiel, oder man macht es nur in absoluten Notfällen. Jemanden um ein Uhr nachts anrufen, da weiß man genau, das macht man nicht, ausser es ist jetzt wirklich ein absoluter Notfall. Und ich möchte dieser Liste hinzufügen, Sprachnachrichten senden. Sprachnachrichten, die sind scheiße. Aber das, glaube ich, ist bei vielen noch nicht angekommen. Nee, ich glaube, das ist auch die einzige auf der Welt, die das so sehen. Nee, das glaube ich eben nicht. Und vielleicht gibt es zwei große Parteien in dieser Welt, die es cool finden, die nicht. Es ist einfach scheiße. Und klar, wenn es irgendwie schnell gehen muss und ich hechte gerade zum Zug und muss noch, muss dir irgendwas gerade ins Handy gurgeln, dann ja oder irgendwie aus Ausnahmegründen oder ich muss dir irgendwas vorsingen oder sowas, weil wir gerade über ein Lied sprechen oder so. Okay, aber generell Wenn wir schon wieder über Lohengrin sprechen. Aber generell ist es scheiße. Ich möchte es einfach mal an die Welt sagen. Seid euch bewusst, dass ihr mit Sprachnachrichten den anderen nervt. Das ist respektlos. Der andere muss jetzt irgendwie alles aufhören, was er gerade tut, muss irgendwie sein Handy an den Kopf halten, muss es hören, es ist unangenehm, alle denken, ist hier kaum mit bescheuert, was passiert. Dass der ganze Meetingraum hört, weil man das verkackt, dass man es ans Ohr hält, glaube ich, leiser wird. Ja. Und dann, und checkt es doch vor allem, dass wenn man euch nicht zurück eine Sprachnachricht aufnimmt, dann der andere offensichtlich dagegen ist. Das ist wie, als die Cowboys auf die Indianer trafen und die mit ihren Rauchzeichen und die dann immer einen Brief zurückgegeben haben. Ja, ja. Und sie denken so, take a hint. Und dann zurückgerufen haben, weil die sich sehen. Leute, okay, ist angekommen, wir kommen um zwölf. Guck mal, dauert es wieder eine halbe Stunde, bis das Feuer wieder an ist. Ja, ja. Und dann fängt es an zu regnen und die Nianer sagen, oh Moment, vielleicht sollten wir einfach auch sprechen mit denen. Könnt wir Gott bitte aufhören, uns grundlos von unserem Land zu vertreiben und, ach komm, scheiß drauf, es funktioniert einfach nicht. Das ist ein scheiss System. Hat sich durchgesetztiß system ja aber dann hat es geregnet und da haben die indianer gemerkt okay wir müssen umsteigen ja also wir müssen sowas wie einen regentanz aufhören damit wir sehr kompliziert diese metapher sehr kompliziert geworden nee wir müssen quasi ein regen eine regen-analogie schaffen damit leute aufhören ra machen. Verstehst du, was ich meine? Und die haben wahrscheinlich auch kein Rauchzeichenwort für Regen. Weil wenn es regnet, dann kann man keine Rauchzeichen senden. Warum nicht? Können die nicht Rauch speichern? Was? Kannst du nicht ein Haus voller Rauch machen immer und dann das da rauslassen, wenn du es brauchst? Sorry, kurz Leute, wir brechen kurz ab. Was?
Kannst du nicht Rauch speichern? Irgendwie in einem Luftballon. Also ja, die haben keinen Luftballon, aber in einer Box. In einer Box. In einer Box. In einer Box. Kann ich einem eine Rauchbox aufmachen? Die haben Box. Die haben Fälle. Box? Ist das eine schöne Fellbox? Ich weiß nicht. Keine Ahnung. Indianer sehe ich seit dem Film Revenant anders. Weil seit dem Film, da forderte ich immer, oh, die taten mir leid, weil die einfach überrannt wurden von den, die dann da kamen. History, Stefan. Und dann ... Von wem? Was? Von den Dänen, die haben die einfach überrannt. Und wo war das? Indien. Wegen Indianer. Rot und Rothäute, die mit diesem roten Punkt Inder auf der Stirn. Und dann Was machen die Däner in Indu?
Land
anbauen.
Und dann sind die da rüber
und haben gesagt, nee, es ist unser Land.
Und dann haben die Indianer
angefangen, die mit feinen Bogen zu beschießen.
Es ist relativ offensichtlich unser Land.
Hier steht ein Haus von uns.
Das heißt wie wir, Indien. Dann haben die gesagt, nee, wir sind Amerika. Und die Indiener haben gesagt, was? Sorry, riesen Missverständnis. Wir räumen unsere Tippi kurz weg. Wir dachten schon sowas, deswegen haben wir so leicht abbaubare Häuser. Ja, das stimmt. Wir hatten immer schon so ein mulmiges Gefühl. Sollen wir hier wirklich bleiben? Wir heißen ganz anders
als in das Land.
Das ergibt überhaupt keine Sinn.
Das macht keinen Sinn. Deswegen haben wir uns nicht
breit gemacht. Wir haben Tippis.
Wir können die Tippis weg tippissen.
Und dann muss man sagen,
aber seit dem Film Revenant
sehe ich die ein bisschen anders.
Der Film sieht wahnsinnig
manchmal sehr dokumentarisch aus
und deswegen dachte ich, ach so waren die
und da sind die wahnsinnig aggressiv
gezeichnet, weil es ja
wilderndes, vergewaltigendes
Volk und so, der Film ist da
sehr einseitig, ich habe Angst vor Indianern
die, ich wäre nicht überlebt
Nicht deine Zeit? Was glaubst du,
in welcher Zeit hättest du besser?
Wärst du richtig aufgegangen?
Weiß ich nicht.
Sechziger Jahre?
In den Achtzigern.
In den Achtzigern werde ich reingepasst, glaube ich.
Die Musik war meine, in der Disco.
Nee, ich glaube, ich wäre ganz gut in der Steinzeit.
Ich glaube, das wäre meine Zeit.
So, Stephanus muss Brot backen heute. Verdammt, verdammt. Die sind so klein. Wir werden wieder alle nicht satt. Ach nee, ich glaube, Mittelalter wäre mein Ding gewesen und so. Ich habe viele Was-is-was-bücher gelesen, über unsere Burg und so. Und der kleine Tim führt einander ganz cool durch. Und man sieht genau, da ist eine Schiesscharte, da kann manwehr reinlegen. Ja, das wissen die aber halt auch schon, die da wohnen. Ach so.
Das ist ja kein Sonderes. Aber die hatten nicht
dieses Was-is-was-Buch, wo man
aufklappt und dann kam eine Burg quasi raus,
so 3D gefaltet mässig. Das war
immer ganz cool. Und dann gab es diese Bücher,
wo man so eine Taschenlampe hatte, und da konnte man,
und das hatten die halt alles nicht, und da war sich halt ein paar Sachen.
Die hatten halt keine Draufsicht,
so dieses Draufsicht von ihrer Burg. Ja, das stimmt. Gab es nicht auch das Das ist ein sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr jeder kennt es? Das ist irgendein psychologischer Effekt, dass Dachdecker andere Menschen anders sehen, weil die die hauptsächlich von oben sehen. Und deswegen Dachdecker so ganz weirde Leute. Ich will jetzt niemanden was aufs Dach legen, was das angeht, aber dass man so sagt so. Die haben Dachschaden. Nee, dass die irgendwie die Umgebung anders wahrnehmen oder so. Die sind wahnsinnig abgehoben vielleicht, weil die immer von oben auf Leute sprechen. Die schreien dann immer an. Ich habe so einen Wahrnehmungstest gemacht und dann hat man herausgefunden, dass Dachdecker und Schornsteinfeger irgendwie die Welt anders wahrnehmen, weil sie ja irgendwie ein Teil des Tages irgendwo oben sind. Und Astronauten, bei denen ist alles normal. Die sind ja nicht so lange oben. Weißt du, so ein Dachdecker ist ja, keine Ahnung, wenn der jetzt jeden Tag acht Stunden arbeitet, davon ist er vier Stunden auf dem Dach, und das über, wie lange arbeitet ein Dachdecker, 20, 30 Jahre lang oder was, keine Ahnung, das ist schon eine Zeit. Ja. Also wenn du dem Dachdecker sagst, mal einen Menschen, dann malt der einen Kreis von oben, ich habe keine Ahnung, ich versuche mir gerade. Ich versuche mir gerade, irgendwas zusammenzureimen, wo ich irgendwann im Buch mal was gelesen habe. Das ist so das Problem. Ich interessiere mich für Dinge, ich lese sie, ich finde sie spannend, aber nach 20 Minuten ist alles weg. Und dann denkt man sich, war es das jetzt wert? Weil generell, Sachen zu lernen ist ja eine sinnvolle Aktiventlich, ich würde sogar sagen, relativ egal, was man lernt. Man lernt was dazu. Das Gehirn lernen zu lernen, das ist auch schon wichtig. Da kann man adaptieren lernen, anpassen lernen. Ist gut fürs Gehirn zu lernen. Aber genau, mein Gehirn ist nicht dafür gemacht, zu lernen, glaube ich. Ich bin wahnsinnig gut und es kann auch an unserem verkorksten Schulsystem liegen. Denn ich habe ein wahnsinnig gutes Kurzzeitgedächtnis. Also für Theaterstücke konnte ich wahnsinnig gut auswendig lernen, in dieses eine Musical, was ich mal gesungen habe. Das war lächerlich viel Text und lächerlich atonal auch und so furchtbar. Und das konnte ich mir wahnsinnig gut drauf schaffen, wo viele gesagt haben, what, wie kann das wohl sein? Aber das ist wahnsinnig viel Text und wahnsinnig viel Töne und da musst du halt Positionen merken und es war einfach sehr viel Kurzzeitgedächtnisaufgabe und das konnte ich gut, aber ich habe jetzt alles verlernt, was ich jemals wusste über, ich weiß nicht mehr, wie dieses Zeichen heißt in Mathe, was aussieht wie eine umgedrehte Drei, nee, nicht immer umgedreht. So die Summe.
Ja, keine Ahnung, dieses Zeichen.
Diese zackige Drei.
Diese zackige.
Ja.
Was ist das für ein Zeichen und wann haben wir das benutzt?
Lambda.
Summe ist das.
Lambda, was ist Lambda?
Eulersche Zahl?
Lambda ist ...
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Das ist alles weg und ich habe damit acht Jahre verbracht.
Bei mir geht es so mit Verkehr manchmal.
Ich bin ja heute hierher gefahren und dann sehe ich dieses Dreieck mit dem schwarzen X. Und ich hab's wirklich gesehen und dachte mir, ich hab keine Ahnung, was das bedeutet. Rechts vor links. Ja, aber rechts vor links geht doch immer. Nee. Manchmal, klar. Also, nee, ja. Der steht auch so, der steht auch so in dem Buch. Nee, ja, ja, aber können die einfach draufschreiben rechts vor links? Ja. Warum nicht? Warum müsst ihr ein Schild dafür machen? Vor allem, ich mache mir das Gefühl, mein Gehirn läuft so auf Autopilot und weckt mich dann so, wenn es eine Entscheidung braucht.
Und dann stehe ich vor halb vollendeten Tatsache, teilweise mitten im
Satz. Also heute zum Beispiel mein
Navigationssystem hat mich in eine Strasse
geleitet, was eine Einbahnstrasse war.
Und dann habe ich mein
Handy beschimpft und habe
gesagt, ah ja, leit mich
schön in eine Strasse, wo ich gar nicht reinfahren kann,
du Ball. Und dann wurde ich erst wach und dann war so, wohin wolltest du mit Ball? Welches Schimpfwort beginnt mit Ball? Und wirklich, mein Gehirn hat bis dahin selbstständig gearbeitet und erst dann so, hey, hey, hey, hey, aufwachen! Schnell, schnell, schnell, und dann, ich hab schon bis Ball gearbeitet, okay, passt, alles, wir sind super, wir sind super in der Zeit, du musst jetzt übernehmen, du Ball.
Ja, du bist wie so ein Chef, der so in deinem Büro ist und du lässt die Mitarbeiter mal machen und die vertraust denen auch, du hast auch keinen Bock mehr.
Und die machen mal für sich so und dann haben sie, aber dann merkst du, die kommen auch erst zu dir, wenn die schon lange ein Projekt gegen die Wand gefahren haben.
Total.
Und dann kommen sie erst rein und tun so, ganz kurz, kannst du uns kurz helfen?
Wir sind bei Ball und bräuchten. Und du merkst schon, der Satz ist verloren. Der Satz führt mir nirgendwo mehr hin. Ich habe es dann noch einigermaßen gerettet, glaube ich, mit Ballkopf. Weil ich dachte mir, als Not, als Grundregel... Dein Handy war beleidigt. Als Grundregel... Er hat funktioniert. Trauerger Smiley. Als Grundregel, jedes Wort plus Kopf ist Schimpfwort. Du Schwachkopf, ja. Du Dummkopf. Das ist nicht das beste Beispiel der Welt. Du Apfelkopf, du dummer Stuhlkopf. Ich glaube, du kannst alles machen und dann Kopf dranhängen und es funktioniert. Modelkopf. Klingt auf eine Art abfällig. Charlize-Ferron-Kopf. Stimmt. Abfällig. Du schweißen Robullock-Kopf. Was ist mit Stefan eigentlich los? Du Steffan. Der hustet die ganze Zeit und macht komische Schimpfhörder. Mir passiert das häufig, ich rede nicht häufig mit mir, aber im Auto schon. Also wenn man flucht vor allem. Ja, ja mir mal auf, ich fühle mich zumindest wahnsinnig beschützt und unsichtbar in Autos. Was weird ist, weil es ist vor allem Glas um dich herum. Leute können da reingucken. Und Leute hören auch, was du sagst. Also wenn Leute auf dem Fußgang vorbeigehen und dann, selbst wenn ich noch kurz am Aussteigen bin und ich mich noch schön aufrege über den Passanten oder über das Auto, das mich gerade rechts vor links weggenommen hat, rege ich mich auf, mache die Tür auf und ich sehe einen Passanten vorbei, der genau gehört, was ich gesagt habe. Aber man fühlt sich wahnsinnig sicher. Ja. Und man denkt so, ich würde das niemals, würde ich aussteigen und dann was sagen. Aber es ist ja gut, weil der Passant kann auch so tun, als hätte er es nicht gehört. Weil auch wenn es eine ineffektive Wand ist, ist es trotzdem eine Wand und man kann so tun, als hätte man es nicht gehört. Wohlgegen, wenn jemand Verrücktes auf der Straße brüllt, kann niemand so tun, als würde man es nicht hören. Wohlgegen, wenn alles im Auto stattfindet, so wenn sich ein Pärchen streitet im Auto, kann man so tun, als ist gut, aber im Restaurant kann man so tun, als würde man es nicht hören. Der Typ, der auf der Straße rumrennt und versucht, verrückte Sachen brüllt, oft hinterm Bahnhof irgendwo betrunken, weirde Sachen brüllt, dem musst du einfach in ein Auto stecken und alles wäre normal. Das ist mal so ein Carsharing-Ding, dass man denen Autos gibt. Ja. Crazy Car. Crazy Guy. Crazy to go. Crazy Guy Car. Perfekt. To go. Ich glaube, so sind Taxifahrer entstanden. Ich bin ja auf dem Carsharing-Markt. Übrigens Wirtschaftsnachrichten. Car to go und Drive now werden fusionieren. Nein. Doch, Kartellamt prüft das gerade noch, aber sieht gut aus, die fusionieren sich, weil die haben Angst vor Google und Konsorten. Die Top drei Namen. Wie wird es am besten klingen, wenn Car2Go und DriveNow zusammenkommen. Platz Nummer drei, Drive2Go. Platz Nummer zwei, Car2Drive. It's a car2drive. Platz know what it means. Drive to drive. Aber wir wissen ja nicht, das wird die große Frage. Mein, was du meinst, wäre go drive. Go, come on drive. Let's go and drive. Also man weiß nicht, wie es heißen würde, aber die haben Angst, dass Google Maps, die wollen auch Carsharing machen und die haben natürlich super krasse Daten. Maps to Maps? Maps to Maps, Drive Maps. Die haben krasse Daten? Die haben krasse Daten, ja. Du brauchst krasse Autos. Du brauchst Daten, du musst ja wissen, wo die Leute sind. Ja. Denn nur dann kannst du gewinnen. Und dann brauchst du aber Autos. Stefan, ich habe einen Artikel, du beigelassen. Wir sind jetzt nicht, um den kommst. Also, das nur mal am Rande, Wirtschaftsnachrichten zum Thema Carsharing. Ich habe Neues ausprobiert, und zwar Elektroroller. Oh, Coop! Nee, Emmy heißt es. Emmy und Coop! Emmy, Coop! Coop gibt's in Berlin! Coopi! Mega! Coopi, Emmy, und erst mal super demütigend, als Registrierung musst du deinen Führerschein in die Kamera deines Handy, du musst ein Video aufnehmen von dir. Ja, genau. Und dann ein Video von dir mit deinem Führerschein abgelehnt. Ja, kam direkt ein Video abgelehnt. Ist ja ein Bild von Larry David geschickt. Wow, das, wer den Gag versteht, schreibt eine Mail, schreibt eine Mail, kriegt was. Der Gag war, weil Florentin mal an einem Flughafen ankam, und dann kam er durch die Passkontrolle, und die Kamera hat hat, Larry David war auf, ach ja, ich hab was vergessen bei der Story, weil Larry David war auf, er trug ein Larry David-Shirt. Und dann hat die Kamera ein Foto gemacht von Larry David auf seinem Shirt. Die Kamera hatte eine Gesichtserkennung und hat genau erkannt, wo das Gesicht ist. Das hat auf jeden Fall nicht funktioniert. Es erfolgten die erbärmlichsten Tage meines Lebens, weil ich hab's nicht gekriegt, diese Rolle anzukriegen. Und es ist immer so irgendwie Hamburg-Sternschanze, Leute, coole Leute, du gehst da hin, he he he he he he he he he he he he he he he he he he he he he Kein Problem, piep piep und dann setzt du dir diesen verlausten Helm auf, setzt dich da drauf und dann drückst du da blind rum und der geht nicht an. Und dann sitzt du da drauf wie der größte Trottel der Welt, geht nicht an und dann das absolut Erbärmlichste, du nimmst den Helm wieder ab, packst den Helm wieder ein und du gehst. Und jeder hat gesehen, dass du gescheitert hast. Stellt sich raus, man muss, bevor man den Roller anmachen kann, ihn den Ständer einklappen. Aber da bin ich nicht drauf gekommen. Ich habe es zweimal separat versucht. Ich habe es zweimal separat versucht. Ich habe es zweimal separat versucht und habe es nicht hinbekommen. Und erst beim dritten Mal habe ich mir gedacht, komm, jetzt roll einfach los und dann versuch anzumachen. Und dann den Leuten darum erklären, dass man nicht verrückt ist. Ja. Nee, ich war schon am Ziel. Sorry. Ja, genau. Ich wollte hier hin. Das klassische. Ah. Ja. Ah, scheiße. Nee, ich bin schon auf dem Weg. Okay. Ja, ich ... Ja. Ja. Ja. Ich komm. Ja, ja. Okay, ich komm nur zurück. Alles klar. Gleich. Für die Leute, die uns überraschenderweise zuhören, Flohnen hat während des Bits sein Handy aus der Tasche genommen. Die Webcam ist an, Leute, ihr könnt euch da gerne reinhören. Aber die macht nur alle fünf Minuten ein Bild. Es ist sehr unwahrscheinlich, dass sie genau bei dem Bitt... Gebt mir drei Minuten. Jetzt muss die ganze Zeit sein Handy. Gebt mir drei Minuten. Das war sehr demütigend, aber jetzt bin ich unterwegs und... Geschwind unterwegs. Wahnsinnig gefährlich. Ja, oder? Man denkt sich einfach, holy shit, Alter, hier ist Laub,
hier ist nass, ich hab keinen Schutz,
wenn ich jetzt gegen eine Wand fahre, warst du das?
Die Straße da draußen ist wahnsinnig gefährlich, mit einem dann klar.
Und vor allem dann... Autos rasen an einem
vorbei, weil die sauer sind, weil du nicht schnell genug bist.
Du bist nicht schnell genug für den Straßenverkehr.
Und dann vor allem die Geschwindigkeitsanzeige
auch suboptimal, wird angezeigt
in miles per hour. Und du denkst
dir erstmal, okay, drei im Sinn, Strahlensatz, 1,6, du rechnest erstmal Ich bin ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, im Sinn, Strahlensatz, 1,6, du rechnest erstmal, wie schnell darf ich fahren, 70 Meilen pro Stunde Innenstadt. Links neben, wir steigen schon so Kampfjets auf, und du merkst, oh fuck. Das ist die Schallmauer, warte mal, Geschwindigkeitsschall, C hoch zwei, du rechnest, während du überfährst, vier Rentner und drei rote Ampeln. Also suboptimal. In Deutschland ein Produkt anzubieten, das in Meilen pro Stunde anzeigt. Das finde ich doof. Ich glaube, das ist doch verboten, ehrlich gesagt. Und du denkst dir einfach, keine Ahnung, wie schnell ich fahren soll. Als ich zum ersten Mal mit Coop gefahren bin, mir ist es auch passiert, ich habe den nicht anbekommen, obwohl ich den schneller reingeklappt habe. Bis mir dann aufgefallen, habe ich die Service-Hotline angerufen und so weiter, meine Miete fing ja auch an, aber direkt daneben stand noch ein Roller und der war die ganze Zeit anders.
Das war meine erste Anmacherfahrung und dann bin ich die ganze Zeit mit Blinker gefahren.
Ich hab den Blinker nicht einfach ausbekommen, weil man müsste ja sagen, okay, Blinker ist klar, runterdrücken, links, hochdrücken, rechts, hoch antitschen, dreimal rechts, Jeder kennt Blinker, wie die Blinker funktionieren. Dann habe ich ihn wieder runtergemacht, er blinkt links. Dann dachte ich mir, okay, wenn ich es wieder hoch mache, dann muss er ja ausgehen. Nein, dann hat er rechts geblinkt. Also bin ich die ganze Zeit mit, und dann habe ich versucht, mit Händen anzuzeigen, wo ich jetzt hin will. Und dann bin ich auch zu schnell gefahren, wegen dieser Miles-Per-Hour-Geschichte.
Es war schwierig.
Und dann ist es einfach unsicher.
Zwei Helme auf, übernasses Laub mit 80 Meilen pro Stunde.
Während es links, rechts, links, rechts. Es war mitten im Sommer in Berlin.
Das war ganz toll, weil die Stadt war, der Himmel war blau,
die Stadt war auf den Beinen, alle hatten Spaß.
Und fiuuung, zischt Stefan vorbei auf seinem Coup.
Vor allem auch, also Elektroroller an sich, gute Idee, aber vor allem, es gab es nicht mal vor Jahren, war so, okay, Elektroautos, jetzt geht's los, aber die sind gefährlich, weil die machen kein Geräusch. Und dann gab es eine grosse Diskussion, ich erinnere mich genau, grosse Diskussion, wie sollen die klingen, weil man kann die ja klingen lassen, wie man will. Also man hat sich darauf geeinigt, für Verkehrssicherheit. Die Top drei, wir kommen heute nicht raus, der Geräusche, die Elektromobilitätsgefährten machen sollen. Platz Nummer drei. Platz Nummer zwei. Hey, hey, aus dem Weg, stopp, hey, hey aus dem Weg, ist ein Loop. Platz Nummer eins. Elektro, elektro. Spritzspan, Spritzspan. Aber es ist vor allem anscheinend, das ist immer so, ich weiß nicht, ob ich mich für Politik interessieren soll. Weil ich denke immer so. In Zeiten wie diesen sollte man es vielleicht tun. Du liest dich dann da rein und du schaust dann Maybret Ilner an und dann guckst du dir das alle an. Aber du denkst dir, also jetzt diese Diskussion, die habe ich damals halt mitverfolgt, im Spiegel gelesen, online. Weil du es lustig fandest. Ich habe es gelesen, aber da ist überhaupt nichts draus geworden. Es war völlig umsonst, weil nichts draus geworden ist. Und ich habe mir auch Gedanken gemacht, na gut, welche Geräusche könnte man denn da machen? Vielleicht irgendein Brummen, aber wie legt man das fest? Kann man vielleicht ein Geräusch machen, das irgendwie dann irgendwie... Nur Hunde hören. Und die können dann... Das vielleicht extrem nervig für Hunde ist, für die blinden Leute, dass der Hund dann reagiert. Genau. Aber für die Taubenhunden oder irgendwas. Genau, weil dann könnte es ja ein Geräusch machen, das irgendwie dann Amseln verscheucht. Oder unterbewusst einem sagt, nee, geh mal weg. Ja, oder kauf dieses Auto. Das bedeutet, zu rennen. Oder Werbung zum Beispiel. Fiat, Fiat, Fiat, Fiat, Fiat, Fiat, Fiat, Fiat, Fiat, Fiat, Fiat, Fiat, Fiat, Fiat, Fiat, Fiat, Fiat, Fiat, Fiat, Fiat, Fiat, Fiat, Fiat, Fiat, Fiat, Fiat, Fiat, Fiat, Fiat, Fiat, Fiat, Fiat, Fiat, Fiat, Fiat, Fiat, Fiat, Fiat, Fiat, Fiat, Fiat, Fiat, Fiat, Fiat, Fiat, Fiat, Fiat, Fiat, Fiat, Fiat, Fiat, Fiat, Fiat, Fiat, Fiat, Fiat, Fiat, Fiat, Fiat, Fiat, Fiat, Fiat, Fiat, Fiat, Fiat, Fiat, Fiat, Fiat, Fiat, Fiat, Fiat, Fiat, Fiat, Fiat, Fiat, Fiat, Fiat, Fiat, Fiat, Fiat, Fiat, Fiat, Fiat, Fiat, Fiat, Fiat, Fiat, Fiat, Fiat, Fiat, Fiat, Fiat, Fiat, Fiat, Fiat, Fiat, Fiat, Fiat, Fiat, Fiat, Fiat, Fiat, Fiat, Fiat, Fiat, Fiat, Fiat, Fiat, Fiat, Fiat, Fiat, Fiat, Fiat, Fiat, Fiat, Fiat, Fiat, Fiat, Fiat, Fiat, Fiat, Fiat, Fiat, Fiat, Fiatheit, niemand sieht dich und es sind drei Leute von mir erschrocken. Einfach, ich fahr durch die Gegend und du fährst einfach mit deinem, wo ich dann wirklich rufen war, hey, hey da, hey da, jetzt komm ich heran, ich brauche, heran, ich brauche sie, heran, ich bin vorbei, bye, bye, bye, dobbler, dobbler, dobbler, dobbler.
Oh, Sketch, Doppler, der immer so redet, hallo, guten Morgen, ich habe mir überlegt, erstmal, gleich die Schallwände an, oh, Doppler, und dann so eine Kreisblende aufs Gesicht, dobbler, du, du, Doppler! Guck mal, das wär doch was für die Kinderserie. Wir beide fliegen auf dem Planeten auf den Doppler-Planeten. Das ist alles doppelt. Ja. Kurze private Frage, ähm, folgende Situation. Was würdest du tun? Du hast diese Seite entdeckt, wo man Kunst erstigern kann. Und dann wolltest du es mal ausprobieren, weil das ist ein Auktionshaus. Und du siehst da dieses Bild und das findest du schön. Und du denkst dir, wow, der Preis des aktuellen Gebots ist wahnsinnig, wahnsinnig weit unter dem Schätzpreis. Wenn wir jetzt viel Auktionsstefan machen, müssen wir neue T-Shirts drucken, wir müssen neue Sticker drucken. Alle meine Gags verpuffen, wir können nicht Fehlauktion Stefan machen. Nur mal so, angenommen Kunstsemmler Stefan, wie wär's denn damit? Na gut, angenommen und dann willst du es mal ausprobieren, so, und du musst auch, du musst noch nichts bezahlen erstmal, musst es nur erst mal dein Gebot abgeben.
Du meinst Ebay oder was? Nee, ein Auktionshaus, ein richtiges Kunstauktionshaus. So, und dann stell dir vor, du biedest dann was, weil der Preis so wahnsinnig weit unter dem Schätzpreis liegt, und dann bekommst du den Zuschlag für dieses Bild. Und du hast dir nicht durchgelesen, wie groß es ist, du weißt auch nicht viel über den Künstler. und dann fährst du nach Düsseldorf, also sehr konkretes Beispiel jetzt, aber du fährst nach Düsseldorf und kommst dann da an und willst das Bild abholen, weil du dann zufällig diesen Zuschlag bekommen hast und das Bild ist riesig und erst mal kommst du dann da mit Jogginghose an, weil du denkst, ja, ich ändere jetzt meinen Style nicht, weil ich jetzt sowas tue. Ja, nur weil ich jetzt einen Rembrandt habe, bin ich immer noch Stefan T. Nur weil ich jetzt genau anfange, das Bild war wirklich schön, und dann habe ich da aufgebunden, bin ich da hingefahren und ich habe nicht genau, ich habe gesehen, wie das ist, dass es groß ist, ich habe nicht gesehen, dass es so groß ist, bin ich mit meinem Auto hingefahren und ich dachte mir, ich ändere meinen Style jetzt nicht dafür. Und dann bin ich da mit Jogginghose und der Typ war schon verwirrt. Da habe ich schon, das wird nichts mit uns, dachte ich da schon zu diesem Zeitpunkt. Und der hat sich auch schon gewundert, der hat auch schon so rausgeguckt, mit welchem Auto ich da bin. Und dann habe ich gesagt, das Bild habe ich hier steigert und dann haben wir das alles gemacht und dann bezahlt und so weiter. Und dann kam er mit seinem Kollegen und ist das Bild reingetragen und es lächerlich groß und dann die schmacht zu sagen ja gut können sie das vielleicht noch mal weg bringen weil ich müsste das noch mal abholen kommen und dann hat er gesagt ja jetzt können die einfach einen transporter leihen was ist ein transporter und dann wusste ich doch nicht muss ja so eine ladefläche hinten haben, die offen ist oder sowas. Aber so ein Pick-up-Truck würde auch nicht reichen. Wie gross ist dieses Bild? Das ist schon gross. Aber vor allem, kriegst du das überhaupt in deine Wohnung? Ja, das schon. Also die Wohnung ist dann voll, die Wand ist dann voll. Kann halt nicht mehr duschen. Und jetzt muss ich, und dann habe ich jetzt fünf, ich habe es dann letterweise wieder eingelagert, und ich habe fünf Speditionen, weil das war meine Zahl. Also die wollten mir keinen Versand anbieten, weil bei denen wäre das sehr teuer. Also habe ich angefangen, weil ich keine Zeit habe, mir das abzuholen extra, wollte ich mir eine Spedition beauftragen, die das abholt. Das kostet nicht so viel, 50 Euro oder sowas, das geht. Und dann habe ich da fünf Speditionen eine E-Mail geschrieben und mir hat keine geantwortet, auf diese weirde Nachricht ein Gemälde abzuholen. Hast du deine Ad-Jogginghose-Mail benutzt? Ja, Jogginghosen Stefan. So kommt es nicht. Niemand davon hat mir geantwortet, weil ich eine komische Firmenpolicy finde. Die können wenigstens sagen, nee. Wahrscheinlich, weil es ein Gemälde ist und weil die sich sowas transportieren, sondern eher Güter, die auch mal eine Schramme vertragen, keine Ahnung, wo deren Grenze ist. Ja, und jetzt liegt es da halt, in Düsseldorf. Und das Auktionshaus hat von mir einfach Geld bekommen, für ein Bild, was die sich jetzt aufhängen können, weil ich keine Ahnung habe, wie ich das nach Köln bekommen soll. Das muss ich mir einen Transporter leihen. Was heißt Transporter? Hier von der BTF einnehmen? Nee, sind zu klein. Wahnsinn. Wenn ihr in Düsseldorf einen Transporter habt, bin ich zu klein. Dann schreibt Stefan. Nee, aber einen grossen, so ein T5 reicht nicht. Kannst du mir das Bild mal zeigen? Hast du ein Bild? Hier ein Bild, hier ein Bild vom Bild. Ich war in meinem Leben wirklich selten so gespannt, was jetzt kommt.
Weil das kann jetzt alles sein.
Das kann jetzt wirklich klassisch,
irgendwie impressionistisch, es kann abgefahrene, moderne Kunst sein, es kann irgendwie,
keine Ahnung, Monatsblutung mit Schwamm auf dem Bild sein.
Dann habe ich dem, das Bild ist wie folgt entstanden,
er hat das dann da hingestellt
und dann habe ich gesagt, meine erste Reaktion war
Oh.
Und seine Reaktion war, gefällt es Ihnen nicht?
Dann habe ich gesagt, ja, doch, es ist wirklich
wahnsinnig schön, aber es
Vielen Dank. Und dann habe ich gesagt, meine erste Rechnung war, oh, und seine Rechnung war, gefällt es Ihnen nicht? Und dann habe ich gesagt, ja, doch, es ist wirklich wahnsinnig schön, aber es ist auch wahnsinnig groß. Und er hat gesagt, ja, wir wissen nicht viel über die Künstlerin, wir glauben, das sieht wirklich fantastisch aus, wir glauben, dass es eine Bühnenbildnerin war, die hat immer so groß gemalt. Ich habe es auch schon gesehen, ich habe mich auch informiert darüber, ich habe nicht genau das abschätzen können, man sieht auch nicht genau, wie groß es ist auf dem Bild, muss man sagen. Dann hab ich gefragt, kann ich ein Foto machen, da hat er gesagt, ja, das ist ihr Bild. Dann hab ich gesagt, ach so, ja, können Sie ein Foto machen? Und dann, das ist das Bild. Es ist wirklich schön, aber es ist halt riesig gross. Das kannst du auf dem Bild nicht sehen, aber das ist ungefähr ein original gross Mensch. Es ist schon sehr gross, aber es passt nicht in so eine Trans... Es passt nicht in... Ich habe jetzt mit einem ganz anderen Bild gerechnet. Ich habe mit so einem verträumten See, beziehungsweise Genden oder so gerechnet. Ich dachte, sein erstes Bild kauft man konservativ. So wirklich so ein... Ist nicht mein erstes Bild. Ich habe mehrere Originale. Aber also was hast du da... Also wenn du sagst, unterschätzwert ... Ich hab die Hälfte vom Schätzwert. Und ist das hier so ein Tausenderbereich? Also, an alle Hörer da draußen, falls ihr den Grund sucht, die Patreon-Unterstützung zu kündigen, jetzt habt ihr ihn offiziell. Wirklich. Weil es verkauft sich nur noch Schrift. Leute, euer Geld ist angekommen, danke. Nee, nee, es war nicht so teuer, machbar. Aber es hat keinen Rahmen, also musst du dann selber einen Rahmen? Das ist eine Leinwand, nö. Oder hat man quasi keinen Rahmen? Über Leinwänden hat es ja oft keinen Rahmen eigentlich. Ja? Denn Pollock hängt ja auch ohne Rahmen. Okay, wow. Guck mal, wenn man in diesem Mischenwissen angekommen ist, wo man auch nicht mehr, wo man selber nicht weiß, aber wo auch niemand widerspricht. Ja, und jetzt steht es da rum und ich überlege mir mal, wie ich es abhole. Wahnsinn, alles ersteigern. Das ist mir, vor allem das war mein Erster, und ein Kollege, der mir das auch gezeigt hat, die Website, der macht das halt relativ häufig, steigert er damit und er hat noch niemals ersteigert. Und ich hatte einfach Glück, weil niemand dieses Bild wollte. Vielleicht finden das Kunstkritiker nicht schön. Ich habe gemerkt, meine Mutter reist oft nach Tibet und anscheinend gibt es da irgendwie krasse Kunstakademien. Die haben unendlich viele Abgänger, aber halt kaum Möglichkeiten, da zu arbeiten. Und deswegen gibt es da wahnsinnig viele Strassenkünstler, die malen hier jedes Bild der Menschheitsgeschichte.
Und die können das halt wirklich perfekt imitieren. Und denen kannst du auch sagen, mal das Bild von meiner Schwester wie ein Monet.
Und dann machen die das halt perfekt.
Und da ärgere ich mich, dass ich da nicht gesagt habe, weil die hat dann so gefragt, ob ihr ein Bild will,
da ärgere ich mich bis heute, dass ich nicht gesagt habe, ich will dieses und jenes Bild, dass wirklich dann perfekt nachgemalt ist.
Von irgendeinem armen tibetanischen Kunstakademie.
Aber die haben da einen Markt draus gemacht.
Filmidee. Wir, so zwei Jungs wie wir, machen irgendwie so einen Urlaub in Tibet, weil sie Bock haben irgendwie und treffen da diesen absurd guten Künstler, der jeden Künstler der Menschheitsgeschichte perfekt nachimitieren kann. Wir nerden uns ein bisschen rein in Werkverzeichnisse, also wo man Bildverschollen ist von großem Künstler, wo man denkt, dass da was ist, wo es vielleicht sogar Skizzen für gibt, wo es vielleicht sogar Beschreibungen von gibt, weil die historisch gut dokumentiert sind. Und dann kommt ein Asteroid und schlägt auf die Erde ein. Wir müssen so Anzüge anziehen. Und dann kommen da Aliens raus aus dem Asteroid. Also krass, krass, wer kann uns helfen? Und wir denken uns erst mal nicht, wir verstecken uns. Aber dann denken wir, wir sind die einzigen, die ... Und dann ... Und dann kommen wir so, und dann, oh, da ist noch ... Und dann schwebt mir was rein, so ein Sprengesetz und dann und dann Moment, jetzt aber dadurch, dass die Aliens haben, irgendwie so Zeitwaffen und dann drehen die die Zeit zurück und dann laufen und dann flage ich dem so ins Gesicht, bam und dann liegt er am Boden und wir denken uns so, Moment mal, unter dem Helm, den die Aliens getragen haben, das Gesicht sieht genauso aus wie ich und ich denke mir, was, Moment mal, wenn die eine Zeitwaffe haben, ist es dann eigentlich nur unsere Gesellschaft in der Zukunft, die zurückkehren? Warum wollen die uns umbringen? Warum sieht alle aus wie ich? Und dann machen wir nochmal so ein und dann müssen wir da rein in das Raumschiff und dann gucken wir die Akten an. Und das dann halt schon krass, weil du hast dann halt sowohl diese moralische Komponente als auch die Action. Ja. Zurück zu Akt 1. Das wäre ein cooler Film, fände ich. Ich glaube, es ist auch ein cooler Film. Kunstfilter. Ich glaube allerdings, dass man das sehr leicht herausfinden kann. Nee. Weil du kannst ja herausfinden, wie alt Farbe ist zum Beispiel. Kannst ja da so eine Elektroden-Zerfallsanalyse-Ding machen. Nee, die Antwort ist sehr einfach, weil es gibt ja den berühmten Kunstfilter, den Kölner Kunstfilter Wolfgang Beltracki, der, der das jahrelang gemacht hat und den einfach auch Kunstwerke, wo man das nicht nachweisen konnte. Der hat dann zum Beispiel, er hat sich dann verraten, weil er genau wie du sagst eine falsche Farbe benutzt hat. Wo er gelacht hat, als jemand den Preis genannt hat. Irgendwie zahlte zwölf Jahre. Moment. Nee, er hat Titanweiss genommen bei einem Bild, wo es beim holländischen Künstler Kampendonk, der zu dieser Zeit noch kein Titanweiss. Und da wurde so etwas aufgeflogen. Aber er hat Bilder gemalt, wo bis so Max Ernst und so einen Scheiss, wo Leute bis heute nicht herausfinden können, wenn er nicht das zugegeben hätte vor Gericht, dass es gefälscht ist. Weil du kannst ja in Ofen packen und mit Farben malen, die es so der Zeit gab und so weiter. In Ofen packen? Ja, in Ofen, dann lässt es einfach altern oder du hängst es in der Kneipe auf,
wo Leute anfangen zu rauchen. Du musst es so
aufbacken oder so, dass dann...
Ich bin noch bei meinem Brötchen.
Du vermischst da Sachen. Aber ich finde es ja auch gut, dass es so
Restauratoren gibt, ne? Also wenn jetzt jemand in einem
Museum, ich glaube, irgendjemand hat irgend so ein
ganz teures Bild, so ein Jugendlicher hat da
reingeboxt und hat das zerrissen,
das Bild, und dann kommt da so ein Restaurator und muss das ausbessern und dann sitzt der da mit so einem Pinsel und denkt sich holy scheiße, jetzt muss ich den Picasso nachmalen, also halt dann so den Übergang malen und denkt sich holy shit, Alter der Typ, der nach dem Banksy-Ding der Restaurator, der das jetzt wieder zusammensetzen muss, der tut mir auch leid. Ja, aber es hat jetzt anwerten. Also nachdem Uhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuh Es sind noch zwei, aber der Kunstmarkt fluktuiert. Und in allen Museen Deutschlands holen die die Scheren raus und sagen, ah, hier auch. Ob jemand schon mal bei Sotheby's oder wo das versteigert wurde, Christy's ein Bild ersteigert hat und danach gesagt hat, das ist zu gross? Sorry, sorry. Stefan Theos Deutscher mit 4,5 Millionen. Oh, oh, Millionen, ich dachte, Euro. 4,5 Euro. Kommt mit seinem gemieteten Cargo-Smart vorbei. Nee, aus seinem Roller. Kommt aus seinem Emmy vorbei und muss das scheiß Bild mit transportieren. Ehrlich. Na ja. Wow, ich bin gespannt, wie das weitergeht, ob du jemals an ein Bild kommst. Meldet euch bei Stefan, falls ihr aus der Gegend Köln und Düsseldorf kommt. Ja, aber ihr merkt es. Früher habe ich mir Kratzleis bestellt, jetzt bestelle ich mir Kunst. Ja, du lernst nicht dazu. Ich lerne nicht, na gut, aber ist mit Anspruch. Postest du das Bild? Nee. Ja, haut rein, du, es ist in Urlaub. Ich bin nächste Woche im Urlaub, aber wir haben letzte Woche schon eine Folge aufgenommen, die wir raushauen können. heißt, wir können wahrscheinlich ununterbrochen laufen, ausser, ich glaube, auch so eine Woche, nämlich übernächste Woche bin ich auch noch im Urlaub. Ja, mal gucken, es muss wahrscheinlich eine Folge ausfallen, ansonsten gucken wir mal, wir versuchen es so nahtlos zu halten, wie es geht, ansonsten vielen Dank fürs Zuhören, vielen Dank an dich, Stefan, vielen Dank an dich, Florentin, und vielen Dank an euch. Vielen Dank an Sebastian für das fantastische Intro, das wir einfach nochmal hören, weil es so schön war. Ja, wir hören mal rein. Und weil es so schön war.
Es ist so schön.
Vielen Dank, Sebastian. Und wir heben ab,
macht's gut und wir heben ab, tschüss.
Das Podcast
UFO mit Stefan und Flo
hebt jetzt ab alle Stationen
Ginko, kommt alle an Bord,
die Reise geht los.
Wir fliegen
in die Podcast-Galaxie, zu neuen Podcast-Planeten, der Mensch war dort noch nie, kommt alle an Bord.
Die Reise geht los.